[Music]
ah downtown L.A this is where we at
Corridor have called home for about a
decade now and in that time there's been
a ton of changes you know we have this
super expensive brand new bridge we have
all these businesses opening shop you
know retrofitting buildings and as nice
as some parts of this area have become a
lot of parts have just gotten way worse
we are ordering Skid Row the trash
problem it's just gotten worse how do
you even get trashed this big like who
throws this away there's apparently been
an uptick of like actual garbage fires
in La you can literally see the remnants
of a trash fire here and you can only
drive by these piles of trash so many
times without just wanting to do
something about it so today we're going
to take a break from our
internet-centric lives and we're gonna
get out there and we're gonna pick up
trash I don't know what the previous
I've been in the creek stop telling me
about the cream
[Music]
we're going to be dressed up as Road
workers you know the old boys from
sector four they're the hardest working
ones around you got my porn hours
hour
pull me out of retirement I thought I
got all my porn hours in now I got my
picking hours to get son let's go four
hours are not applicable to trash
picking I think I said porn it's her
first day as a sector four boy so take
it easy she's transferred in from sector
five I think you know last time we were
able to get by with just some janky
safety gear but this time we're going to
pull on yeah this is there is a real
danger of biohazard and disease so we
are actually taking extra precaution we
got salmon Ren back to keep watch over
us Sam the union boss and ren the city
councilman you guys you guys need to
clear that with a broom here we are
running behind schedule hurry up this
whole City's forming part there's crime
and garbage everywhere we're forced to
do this job we have no we have no saying
it we're all actually criminals and this
is part of our punishment Let's uh let's
get officials so people know that we are
actually at City Detachment sector four
it's not official but we have to pretend
that we're actually working for the city
yeah yeah
make it cute I'm picking up trash I got
I got him glasses we have like a truck
to like fill up with trash hopefully
it's like all the trash is accessible
with with wheels trash we're coming to
get you
foreign
[Music]
up today everyone this is going to be a
great campaign day
so right now we're just kind of driving
around scoping for some deposits dude oh
my God look at that one that's a good
one there's a teepee
there's a trash teepee I think we found
a good area here oh we got it there's a
deposit we hit the jackpot baby oh my
gosh this is the mother lode right here
this is too dirty too dirty for you boys
this requires the sector five boys this
is it boss guys if we can pull this off
I think we can become the sector five
boys
this is kind of a taste of what we're
going to be dealing with today I I don't
think we're in a diabetic hot spot right
now this street I can't believe how much
trash there is here oh dude look at this
croissant that's like a age it's
croissant that's a finely aged croissant
you guys probably don't even recognize
this but there's been like a lot of
video shot right here anime fidget
Spinners was shot right here in this
little cross section back in the early
days of my political career this street
was one of wonder
but there was also Turtle danger turtle
I don't know how any business functions
when you have a perimeter of stinking
sludge around your building
the great Mega City one what are we
really trying to do here do you want it
to like do we you want us to actually
get this whole place cleaned or do you
want us to just make it like look clean
listen we need to do whatever we need to
do to make it look like we've done
something are we gonna take pictures to
you here or like is this gonna be yes I
was hoping to get
as you know okay I'll see what I can do
okay so please watch out for the bucket
of poop I think we need Baggers we need
some Pinchers we definitely need a
Forker and a shoveler
[Music]
I go to a steak bed
look at all this
[Music]
hearing you gag makes me want to gag so
if you could like keep it down a little
bit
we're just gagging bags
yeah then I thought changing baby's
diapers was bad this is like changing
the city's diaper right now
thank you
sir don't look we're not going to want
to look in there guys we got more human
remains
oh
my God
[Music]
I'm serious Nick be careful dude she's a
legit biohazard though this bag is full
first bag is full good job everybody
first bag boss good all right that's one
down I think honestly uh probably have a
hundred left to go
I don't know what the cream is man I
don't know what the cream is not telling
me about the cream
if you ain't gagging you ain't gagging
I think I'm having a heart attack this
is pretty tough it's a lot harder than I
thought it was going to be here I don't
know it's gonna take a while you know I
tried to get Mr councilman over there to
get us a skid steer or something uh with
a little more lifting capabilities uh
but now he wanted human labor
work smarter than art we found a cart
that's part of the trash and now it's
our trash Boulder
what do you got freaking camera bag oh
wow nice I don't know if I want
hepatitis from a bag
oh God Nick Savage it's kind of a gross
activity it is such a beautiful day
today and it is getting more beautiful
by the minute
I need a break hey boss I think we need
a break Bob is break up yeah yeah let's
hop back in uh five
I feel like my whole life at Corridor
started in this Alleyway the first time
I ever met samaniko we went and filmed
the Minecraft video literally right
there the first time I'd ever been to La
was in this alley yeah this is where we
shot so many videos including but not
limited to the original Minecraft video
we shot anime fidget Spinners back here
we shot wizard battle back here we shot
judge drone back here so many videos in
this alley and we haven't been able to
film in it for the last few years
because every time we come down here it
looks like this not to mention dude
there's some like world-class graffiti
art on these walls right here would you
just take this in like look at all this
lettering bro what what's it usually
like shoot videos so much around this
area you kind of start feeling like it's
your home a little bit you know to see
it full of trash like this and just
right it's a shame left to the Wayside
hopefully we come back and it's still
kind of clear all right brakes up come
on
hip hip
all right
[Music]
I hate my life it's like a never-ending
stream of trash there's so many other
things
I would rather be doing
thank God I have glasses on to protect
myself from the street dust
hey boss is that truck trying to get
through here I don't know this is a big
[__] up they got the Specter two boys in
on the spot this is supposed to be our
spot but we gotta bring this truck back
here because we're bringing tow trucks
around to this side here to pull some
Vehicles out well I guess we're doing
some public good already because these
gentlemen came in here to pick up a load
of something on a flatbed and the driver
had to do a backwards turn into this tea
alley right here and there's almost no
way he would have been able to do that
if that heap of trash had still been
there so it's already helping out people
in this area which is great to see like
I'm like a little frustrated because
sector 2 sucks ass you know but they're
doing some good work I gotta commend
them at the end of the day it's all
about community and sector two is
helping our community as well
we're making some dents uh we're
actually getting further than I thought
I didn't think we're gonna actually
clear up this much of it but everyone's
kicking ass
yeah one of the reasons it's so
important that we're actually cleaning
up these trash piles is because there's
been a huge surge of trash fires in
recent years so a mushroom wholesale was
in this facility but because of the
fires that have happened in the alleyway
that entire business is now shut down
and this Warehouse is just sitting here
empty this gentleman owns this building
right here that's correct I appreciate
you guys are here we have uh three years
we just keep competing to the city but
City days no response for this matter we
have a bunch of the fire because of this
apparently you have a door that's also
jammed yeah it goes to your Warehouse
yeah I didn't even see there was a door
over here emergency door where can we
move the dumpster on the side maybe I'm
gonna send the forklift over here to put
them on the street to take them off okay
okay thank you much guys great job thank
you appreciate it real life side quest
just appeared the most messed up part
about this is that this is an emergency
door for fires and there's been Three
Fires back here literally combustible
trash piles blocking the fire door get
through the fire door because there's
trash blocking it which literally caused
the fire big goals right now clear
Kevin's door Kevin's then going to take
the dumpsters of a forklift out the
street hopefully the city will remove
them finally
[Music]
thank you
is the gate stuck
[Music]
the baskowski just touched that game man
he's not allowed to do that that's
against Union I don't think he has his
gate and hours
I think I I think I made a big mistake I
just touched something
you didn't see me I just touched the
gate I touched the gate and I pulled it
away from the dumpster I actually did
see that and it was wonderful to see the
union boss putting in hard pouring hours
on a day like this I mean I think Sam is
obviously the second biggest Hero of the
Day behind me I just went above and
beyond you know that's that's what we
call that it's called going above and
beyond because I didn't have to do it
everyone else clean it up they have to
do this so they're not going above and
beyond yet but Kevin just got that
dumpster towed but we got a bunch of
other crap over here so let's just
finish clearing this out for him for
condensing the dry safe trash into one
pile over here I feel like it can be
more easily picked up maybe the city
would feel less threatened or like it's
an easier task maybe to come pick up one
pile of like wood and cardboard and old
furniture as opposed to like biohazard
material
hey
yeah
you guys can use it now yeah man thank
you for sure man thanks man I'm so
impressed and excited to see that now if
there is a like potentially catastrophic
fire here that they will be able to
escape with their lives it's not just
clean it's the streets are safer it
looks way better I'm happy we did it I
would wear like a like a shower cap next
time better than that it's kind of crazy
to see what six people can just come out
here and do yeah a whole city is just
letting it kind of crumble here's what I
noticed the moment that we started doing
something about it other people came by
to chip in yeah when people see
something positive they want to be a
part of it and they want to join in on
it I was glad we were able to come down
here and make a dent at this place that
we filmed so much of little acts of
service go a long way what we're doing
here is truly incredible don't you think
I'm so proud of myself right now I think
we're about ready to get those campaign
photos our citizens are going to be so
proud of me all right well everyone make
sure you complete the camera great all
right and cheese
[Music]
thank you
foreign